[Music]
yo I'm Luke Cage don't test me you know
where to find me everybody talking about
Luke Cage like he's Jesus ain't no I
just elect Mike smoke bulletproof black
man for the Hard Rock's he's a gentle
boogey man of their nightmare you should
get a snack with this really guys I
don't know we try it man I know you
can't keep doing what you're doing
I have no idea what you're talking about
and believe me Luke Cage is nothing but
a man
[Music]
eylem it's mine
damn hate to see such a positive brother
like luke age go down like that you
hurts you
you're not invulnerable Luke anyone who
could take you on bear and it can't be
good for Harlem I gotta find him monster
who makes me so scary you hope you never
have to find out
it's a wishmaster
[Music]
I've seen you raw I'd never do that
sometimes pretending to get [ __ ] done
own doesn't need a heroes in these a
queen the darkness that you deal with
every day
we can't conceal them to hold it
don't let just to be clear a lot in the
market for a sidekick possession of my
sidekick me it's my show
[Music]